Kapsel auf for Europe Madam Secretary of
the parlamentary assembly members of the
parlamentary assembly ladies and
gentlemen
when human lifes and dangered when human
dignity is in jeopardy national borders
and centilities become Avant
dieser words of Ally wieso the holocause
survival mit noble piesen hat die
Holocaust Überlebende
gesprochen er hat sein Leben lang daran
geglaubt sich stark zu machen für
Menschenrechte ganz gleich wo
Verletzungen auftreten und wer davon
betroffen ist
er war überzeugt dass wenn
Menschenrechte verletzt
werdensignal ist für das was noch kommen
wird
der Europarat wurde 1949 gegründet und
zwar genau vor diesem Hintergrund als
Frühwarnsystem gegen
Menschenrechtsverletzungen
um neue Kriege zu verhindern
menschliches Leiden zu verhindern und
Tyrannei auf europäischen Boden
willkommen European home for the marker
gemein europäisches Heim für die
Demokratie und Rechtsstaatlichkeit für
alle Europäerinnen und Europäer
geschützt durch starke Mauern die durch
den Europäischen
Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte und die
Menschenrechtskonvention geschützt sind
es gibt über 220 Konventionen und
Verträge in diesem Haus und wenn wir
offen sind dann weiß wahrscheinlich
niemand der Anwesenden mit Ausnahme des
Präsidenten vielleicht
wäre in der Lage alle diese Konvention
zu nennen das
zeigt aber wie viele bilaterale Verträge
werden bräuchten um all diese Konvention
zu ersetzen ohne die Konventionen ohne
den Europäischen Gerichtshof und seine
Mechanismen
hätten wir nicht die Lage die wir heute
haben mit dem der Europarat die höchsten
Standards ethisch setzt wir schützen so
Frauen im Kampf gegen häusliche Gewalt
es geht um Pressefreiheit und wir die
Regierungen
können so auch Menschen mit
Behinderungen den Zugang zu freien
Wahlen
außerdem
drängt der Gerichtshof derzeit auf
intergenerationelle Gerechtigkeit in
bahnbrechenden Fällen wie zum Beispiel
in Hinblick auf die Klimakrise dieser
direkt Zugang den Individuen haben zu
diesem internationalen
Menschenrechtsgerichtshof ist
einzigartig auf der Welt
aus diesem Grund hat Deutschland weitere
Gelder für den Hof bereitgestellt und
wir fordern auch andere auf und ich
möchte das jetzt ganz offen hier sagen
wir fordern die anderen dringend auf
auch ihre Unterstützung zu erhöhen
denn wenn wir wollen dass der
Gerichtshof auch in Zukunft
handlungsfähig ist dann braucht er die
entsprechenden finanziellen Ressourcen
ich möchte hier ganz klar sprechen der
Europäische Gerichtshof für
Menschenrechte ist etwas auf dass wir
stolz sein können
wir Konvent sind aber auch zu sozialen
Konventionen und Resolutionen
verpflichtet wir wollen eine faires
Einkommen garantieren und wir können
nicht erwarten dass Richterinnen und
Richter immer mehr Arbeit leisten
die Regierungen müssen deswegen den
Gerichtshof Stärken unseren europäischen
Menschenrechtsgerichtshof in der Zukunft
der Gerichtshof spiegelt die Überzeugung
der Mitgliedsstaaten des Europarats
wieder das unsere Regierungen die
fundamentalen Rechte der Menschen an
erste Stelle setzen müssen
aber wenn wir ehrlich sind dann
es ist wahrscheinlich so dass wieder wir
alle zugeben müssen
dass wir vor der Zeit als
parlamentarier:innen und politiker:innen
vermutlich
manchmal ein bisschen verwirrt waren
wenn man sie gefragt hat was in der
Unterschied zwischen dem Europarat und
dem Europäischen Rat ist
und wussten wir denn zum Beispiel alle
dass die Hymne Europas und die
europäische Flagge mit den 12 Sternen
zuerst vom Europäischen Rat verwendet
wurde
der Präsident hat heute morgen noch mal
unterstrichen dass Copyright keine Rolle
spielt in diesem Zusammenhang solange
die EU
endlich die europäische Konvention für
zum Schutz von Menschenrechten
ratifiziert oder kopiert
aber ich meine das ernst das ist nichts
Schlechtes als Journalist kann man jetzt
natürlich schreiben oh die Leute kriegen
in Europa hat und den EU-Rat bringt das
Durcheinander das zeigt dass der
Europarat nicht so wichtig ist aber ich
glaube das stimmt überhaupt nicht ich
glaube dass junge Menschen und selbst
diejenigen meiner Generation ich bin
jetzt 42
das große Glück haben dass ihr ganzes
Leben in Frieden gelebt haben nicht
unter einer Diktatur und das liegt bei
mir daran dass ich in Westdeutschland
geboren wurde für uns sind Freiheit und
demokratiert was das wert
selbstverständlich ansehen aber nicht
weil wir sie vernachlässigt haben
sondern weil unsere Vorfahren diesen
Europarat aufgebaut haben und wir
glauben alle an dieses Haus der Freiheit
des Friedens in dem wir gemeinsam für
immer leben können das ist unsere
Grundannahme deswegen geht es gar nicht
darum ob der Europarat eine ausreichend
starke Rolle in der Vergangenheit
gespielt hat die wichtige Frage ist was
wir jetzt tun jetzt wenn die europäische
friedensgrenze bedroht ist der Europarat
die OSZE alle attackiert werden das ist
unsere Verantwortung
unserer Generation unserer Zeit denn der
russische betriebskrieg ist nicht nur
einer gegen die Ukraine sondern einer
gegen die gemeinsamen europäisch gegen
die gemeinsame europäische
Friedenspolitik
was wir in den letzten Monaten getan
haben war deswegen entscheidend ich
möchte sie alle hier auch im Rat
beglückwünschen dazu dass sie Putin
bewiesen haben dass er niemals
erfolgreich sein wird in seinem Versuch
die Ukraine zu zerstören und dass er
auch niemals erfolgreich sein wird im
Versuch unser gemeinsames
friedenshaus zu zerstören und das ist
der Europarat wir müssen uns aber auch
Fragen über uns selbst stellen denn wir
haben auch gesehen was wir in der
Vergangenheit vernachlässigt haben zu
sehr vernachlässigt haben und das ist
das Frühjahr früh Warensystem dieses
Europa hat indem wir hier sind denn wenn
Menschenrechte mit Füßen getreten werden
dann ist das ein frühwagen System oder
ein Signal dass wir handeln müssen
solche Warnsignale gab es in der
Vergangenheit als unsere Freunde und
Partner in
in zentralen Europa vor allem in der
baltischen Region gesagt haben dass ich
da in Russland etwas tu dann haben
unsere Länder vor allem meines nicht
sorgfältig genug zugehört als wir
gesehen haben was mit Alex passiert ist
als wir gesehen haben wie Russland die
Urteile des Europäischen Gerichtshofs
nicht beachtet und als wir gesehen haben
wie Russland sich geweigert hat die
Istanbuler Konvention zu unterzeichnen
und Frauenrechte unterminiert hat dann
hätten wir erkennen müssen dass das
Warnsignale waren aber wir haben sie
nicht gesehen wir haben nicht gehandelt
schon 2017 hat Russlands seine Gesetze
zu häuslicher Gewalt verändert so dass
Männer Ehemänner Partner die ihre Frauen
verprügeln
keine rechtlichen Probleme mehr bekommen
zumindest nicht während sie ihre Frauen
verprügeln das Gesetz wurde jetzt
geändert man muss seine Frau
mehrmals geschlagen haben sie muss ins
Krankenhaus eingewiesen worden sein erst
dann werden die Gerichte aktiv seit 2017
in Russland ich denke das ist eine klare
und deutliche Warnung denn
Menschenrechte sind ein Indikator für
den Zustand unserer Demokratien wenn
Frauen in einer Gesellschaft nicht
sicher sind dann ist niemand sicher
wenn Menschenrechte in einem Land nicht
respektiert werden dann wird es
letztlich
ein Risiko für Frieden und Freiheit
Präsident Putin hat das offensichtlich
gezeigt seine
vergewaltigungssprache seine
Aggressionen zu Hause im eigenen Land
gehen Hand in Hand mit dem Versuch die
Ukraine zu zerstören wie auch unsere
Friedensordnung hier in Europa deswegen
bin ich überzeugt dass der Europarat
heute ist mit seinem Frühwarnsystem
wichtiger denn je ist sein Einsatz für
die menschenrate Macht bewegt einen
wichtigen Unterschied für die Menschen
überall in Europa
und ich möchte die unterstreichen dass
Europa größer als nur die EU ist die
Menschenrechtskonvention und der
Europäische Gerichtshof sind ein
gemeinsames Haus für europäische
Menschenrechte und Demokratie für fast
700 Millionen Menschen
700 Millionen Menschen die Gott sei Dank
nicht gleich aussehen die nicht
dieselben Träume haben die verschiedene
Traditionen verschiedene Geschichten
haben und verschiedene Pläne für die
Zukunft
doch diese 700 Millionen Menschen sind
alle vereint durch ihren festen Glauben
an grundlegende Rechte
ich hatte das Privileg zu sehen was das
wirklich bedeutet grundlegende Rechte
fundamentale Rechte Teenager ich habe
mich mit Teenagern unterhalten in Archiv
diesen Monat
und habe auch verschiedene zerstörte
Orte dort besichtigt aber was mich am
meisten berührt hat war
als ich an einem an einer Stelle
eingehalten habe wo man sich aufwärmen
konnte das wurde mit so viel Liebe
eingerichtet wir saßen da um ein Ofen
herum und hat uns Kekse angeboten und
einen Tee draußen hat es -12 Grad und
ich saß da zusammen mit verschiedenen
Teenagern
die Schule in die sie davor gegangen
waren war schon am Anfang des Kriegs
zerstört worden
da habe ich sie gefragt wo geht ihr denn
jetzt zur Schule
die haben mich angeschaut und gesagt
unsere Schule wurde zerstört
diese jungen Menschen
gehen nicht mehr zur Schule weil nicht
nur ihr Schulgebäude zerstört wurde
sondern auch viele andere Schulgebäude
in der Stadt innerhalb des letzten
Jahres und sie waren seit über einem
Jahr nicht mehr oder fast einem Jahr
nicht mehr in der Schule weil es
gefährlich wäre zur Schule zu gehen denn
fünf Kilometer von der russischen Grenze
entfernt wenn eine Rakete dort
einschlägt
die auf diese Stadt
abgefeuert wird wie es schon passiert
ist dann gibt es kein
Luftverteidigungssystem das
sicherstellen kann dass die Schule
dieser Teenager nicht erneut getroffen
wird es gibt 45 Sekunden Zeit sich zu
verstecken 45 Sekunden ist natürlich
viel zu wenig Zeit um sich in Sicherheit
zu bringen da kann man nur noch beten
[Musik]
ich habe die Teenager gefragt was macht
ihr denn wenn er nicht zur Schule geht
und das beeindruckende war dass es sogar
in einer teilweise zerstörten Stadt ist
online Unterricht gibt
ich habe sie gefragt was sie denn sonst
noch so tun wenn man nur 45 Sekunden hat
indem man nur noch beten kann weil man
sich nicht mehr in Sicherheit bringen
kann
eines der Mädchen sagte mir ich habe
früher Volleyball gespielt aber
natürlich gibt es auch mein
Volleyballfeld inzwischen nicht mehr ich
bin 16 Jahre alt normalerweise hänge ich
gerne mit meinen Freunden ab aber das
geht auch nicht mehr
obwohl diese Schülerinnen und Schüler
überlebt haben
leben sie jetzt kein normales Leben
eines Teenagers mehr sie verstecken sich
jeden Tag jede Nacht sie beten dass die
nächste Rakete sie nicht treffen wird
als ich sie dann gefragt habe warum seid
ihr denn nicht geflüchtet hat diese
16-Jährige mir gesagt ich bin nach
Italien gereist geflüchtet mit meinen
Eltern
aber sie ist zurückgekehrt und da habe
ich sie gefragt warum bist du denn
zurückgegangen
in dieser gefährliche Nachbarschaft in
diese Nachbarschaft ein Viertel das gar
nicht mehr existiert weil es von Bomben
zerstört wurde dort stand in einem
teilweise zerstörten Haus noch ein Tisch
ich habe gesehen wie die Leute da
wahrscheinlich noch saßen und Kaffee
getrunken haben bevor die Rakete
eingeschlagen hat und das Mädchen hat
mit Tränen in den Augen geantwortet weil
das mein Zuhause ist auch wenn mein
Zuhause jetzt ein Gefängnis ist weil ich
nicht zur Schule gehen kann weil ich
nicht zum Volleyball gehen kann weil ich
keine Zeit mit meinen Freunden mehr
verbringen kann aber das ist mein
Zuhause meine Heimat hier will ich sein
hier will ich überleben
hier will ich leben wenn ich denn nicht
sterbe
Leonie sing this girl das einzige was
dieses Mädchen und all ihre Freunde und
Freundinnen wollten war einfach ein
normales Leben zurückzubekommen ein
Alltag in dem man rausgeht als Teenager
um seine Freunde zu treffen und wurde
bald zu spielen und um zur Schule zu
gehen
dieser einfache Wunsch nach einem Leben
in Freiheit und Frieden mit
grundlegenden Menschenrechten
zeigt wie wichtig die Arbeit des
Europarats ist
oder wenn man das jetzt noch größer
ausdrücken will wie Konrad Adenauer
gesagt hat hier im Europarat als er
gegründet wurde
der Europarat ist die Seele Europas es
ist unsere Pflicht diese Seele am Leben
zu halten
aus diesem Grund sind wir hier deshalb
spreche ich hier als deutsche
Außenministerin deswegen sind sie alle
hier und kommen jeden Monat wieder in
dieses Haus um sich für unsere
europäische Seele stark zu machen um sie
für jeden Europäer und jede Europäerin
zu retten für die Teenagerin
um sicherzustellen dass wir die frühen
Warnsignale für
Menschenrechtsverletzungen nicht
verpassen die zu Krieg und Gewalt führen
können und um sicherzustellen dass die
Freiheiten von allen Menschen jeden Tag
besser geschützt werden das Recht auf
ein Leben in Würde und Freiheit
ja ich glaube dass wir den Europarat
heute mehr denn je brauchen um die Macht
dieser Rechte über die Macht des
Stärkeren zu setzen
Präsident Putin
möchte Machtpolitik Spielen in denen
Staaten individuell Rechte mit fußen
treten können indem man in den in ein
imperialistisches Gedanken ist System
zurückfallen kann in dem Menschen
einfach nur
Spielfiguren auf einem Schachbrett sind
deswegen war jetzt im Krieg von Russland
gegen die Ukraine Neutralität keine
Option wir mussten die Wahl treffen
zwischen Gerechtigkeit und
Ungerechtigkeit zwischen Freiheit und
Unterdrückung
zwischen dem stehen auf dem auf der
Seite des Unterdrückers und
dem stehen auf der Seite der
Unterdrückten und wir haben die richtige
Entscheidung getroffen wir haben
eine eindeutige Haltung gegen den
Angriffskrieg Russlands eingenommen wir
haben gemeinsam dafür gestimmt Russland
vom Rat auszuschließen und wir haben
sichergestellt dass der Rat an den an
Seite der mutigen Ukraine ihnen steht
die sich für Freiheit und ihr Land stark
machen die dafür kämpfen aber auch für
Demokratie und Rechtsstaatlichkeit auf
dem gesamten europäischen Kontinent
denn der Europarat ist kein
geografisches Konzept
denn der Europarat vereint uns im
Konzept der Menschenrechte Demokratie
und Rechtsstaatlichkeit
wir müssen aber auch kritisch
hinterfragen warum wir die
frühwarensignale nicht vollständig
erkannt haben beim letzten Treffen der
Ministerin und Minister in Turin im
Sommer habe ich mich deswegen für den
vierten Gipfel des Europarats stark
gemacht der jetzt im Mai unter der
isländischen Vorsitz in Reykjavik
stattfinden wird dieser Gipfel wird eine
Möglichkeit zur Neuausrichtung der
Organisation in dieser neuen Ära
europäischer Geschichte sein wir wissen
dass Institutionen nur so stark wie die
politischen finanzielle Unterstützung
sind die sie erhalten das heißt wir
müssen dem Europarat finanzielle und
andere Mittel an die Hand geben die es
benötigt der benötigt sich anfangs schon
gesagt habe diese Ehre die geprägt ist
durch den Krieg Russlands können wir den
Fortschritt der Freiheit und
Menschenrechte in Europa nicht mehr für
selbstverständlich ansehen grundlegende
Rechte und erhalten und werden bedroht
an zu vielen Fronten
wenn wir zeigen wollen dass trotz der
Repressalien und des Kriegs die Kraft
der Demokratie und die Seele Europas
ungebrochen bleiben auf unserem
Kontinent
dann müssen wir aufstehen und sie
verteidigen für sie kämpfen
das dürfen wir nicht vergessen bei den
Vorbereitung für den Gipfel in Reykjavik
wir bauen darf auf unsere wertvollen
Idee und Vorschlägen auf und es gibt da
ja ganz viele Ideen und Vorschläge ich
habe vor einigen Tagen eine Entscheidung
getroffen und möchte mich bei diesem
Gefühl auf drei Punkte konzentrieren
erstens sollten wir unsere gemeinsame
Verpflichtung
zu den Kernwerten des europawärts
unterstreichen
wenn der Europarat unser gemeinsames
Haus und unsere gemeinsame Seele für die
europäische Demokratie und
Menschenrechte bleiben soll da müssen
wir die Risse in den Wänden wieder
kitten und die Erosion des Fundaments
aufhalten und sicherstellen dass alle
BewohnerInnen sich an die Hausregeln
halten
mir ist bewusst dass unsere 46
Mitgliedsstaaten
ganz verschiedene Geschichten und
verschiedene Kulturen haben eine
unterschiedliche Vergangenheit mir ist
klar dass kein Rechtssystem und keine
Demokratie perfekt ist Gott sei Dank
denn kein Mensch ist perfekt wir sind
alle unterschiedlich aber was wir uns
alle wünschen ist jeden Tag besser zu
werden
gibt nicht perfekt die eine richtige
Demokratie was uns alle verbindet hier
im Europarat ist unsere Verpflichtung
zur Rechtsstaatlichkeit und zur zum
Mächtegleichgewicht
wir möchten die fundamentalen Rechte
unserer Bürgerinnen und Bürger schützen
sowie ihre Freiheiten
dafür sind wir hier ich möchte es laut
und deutlich sagen alle Mitgliedsstaaten
müssen die Europäische
Menschenrechtskonvention respektieren
und die Urteile des
Menschenrechtsgerichtshofs umsetzen und
respektieren
die türkischen Behörden
ignorieren seit Jahren
unsere Aufforderung aus man Kavala
freizulassen für den menschenrechtshof
ist seine Verhaftung war seine
Verhaftung und Festnahme seine
Inhaftierung gegen Menschenrechte
nothing to plaud about wir können uns
aber jetzt nicht über die jetzige
Situation freuen denn Osman Kavala
sollte nicht im Gefängnis sitzen
wir können es nicht akzeptieren dass ein
Mitgliedsstaat dieses Rats jemanden aus
politischen Gründen inhaftiert deswegen
hat der ministerausschuss jetzt ein
Verfahren gegen die Türkei eingeleitet
das wurde vor kurzem noch mal bei einem
Besuch unterstrichen und ich möchte die
Europäer die türkischen Behörden noch
mal auffordern Osman Kavala freizulassen
und die anderen
die laut des menschenrechtshofs
unrechtmäßig inhaft sitzen
[Applaus]
als Mitglieder dieses Rats müssen diese
Regeln akzeptieren das ist eine
rechtliche Verpflichtung das ist keine
kein Wunschzettel
das erwarten unsere Bürgerinnen von uns
surprise und das gilt natürlich auch für
alle Länder in diesem Raum auch
für mein eigenes Land deswegen hat
Deutschland jetzt Maßnahmen auf den Weg
gebracht
Instrument des Europarats zum Schutz von
Mädchen und Frauen jetzt vollständig
umzusetzen denn wir können nicht von
anderen erwarten solche Konventionen
umzusetzen und zu ratifizieren wenn wir
selbst irgendwelche
zögerlichen Verhaltensweisen zeigen
deswegen
hat meine Regierung vor einem Jahr
gesagt dass Deutschland nicht mehr
zögerlich hinsichtlich der Istanbuler
Konvention sein wird wir werden die
Konvention ab nächsten Monat vollständig
ohne Einschränkung umsetzen ich möchte
alle Mitgliedstaaten die die Konvention
unterzeichnet haben aufrufen sie
ebenfalls bald zu ratifizieren und ich
denke wenn ein Land das sich im Krieg
befindet wie die Ukraine dazu in der
Lage war dann kann jedes Land das im
Frieden lebt das auch schaffen
unsere Arbeit als Teil der eu-
Trauer ein bisschen gleichzeitig sollten
unsere Ziele für den Gipfeln Reykjavik
sich nicht nur darauf beschränken was
der Europarat schon erreicht hat so
wichtig wie das vielleicht auch ist
gemeinsam können wir unser gemeinsames
Haus für Demokratie und Menschenrechte
nicht nur renovieren wir können das auch
ausbauen damit neue Menschen daran Platz
haben das bringt mich zu meinem zweiten
Punkt wir müssen zusammenarbeiten um den
rate Demokratie und die Demokratie an
eine Welt zu anzupassen die sich
verändert und das heißt dass wir die den
Beitritt so
Europäischen Menschenrechtskonvention
endlich
umsetzen müssen das muss ein
Menschenrechtsschutz Standard werden
der Rat kann aber vor allem helfen den
Weg für eine neue Generation der
Menschenrechte zu ebnen die Demokratie
und Menschenrechte bauen auf universale
Werte auf aber das ist auch eine Arbeit
die man immer weiterführen muss denn
unsere Gesellschaften verändern sich es
gibt neue Technologien wie wir alle
wissen
die digitale Revolution z.B verändert
unser Einkaufsverhalten wie wir Freunde
treffen und wie wir auf Dates gehen für
die die gedatet haben
sie verändern verändert wie unsere
Branchen funktionieren oder wie
Wissenschaftlerinnen Stürmen und Dürren
hervorsagen soziale Medien das Internet
und künstliche Intelligenz haben unsere
Leben schon so stark verbessert aber
natürlich gehen sie auch mit neuen
Risiken und Herausforderungen einher wir
haben gesehen dass KI Gesichtserkennung
teilweise rassistisch agieren kann
Kinder werden attackiert mit aggressiver
Werbung und
manche Regime verwenden KI und
Gesichtserkennung auch gegen ihre
bürger:innen deswegen müssen wir
zusammenarbeiten um Menschenrechte in
der digitalen Welt zu schützen
wir können das nicht in Algorithmen
tiktok oder Elon Musk überlassen
das ist eine politische Aufgabe eine
demokratische Aufgabe
im Europarat arbeiten wir einer
Konvention zu Entwicklung und
Ausgestaltung
ki-entwicklung und das kann ein
europäischer Standard sein für
menschenrechtsbasierte KI
so können wir sicherstellen dass
Unternehmen und Regierungen
Menschen nicht ausspionieren durch
soziale Medien Analysen mit KI wir
können sicherstellen dass Technologie
die Menschenrechte stärkt nicht schwächt
denn Technologie gibt es für die
Menschen und nicht für die Wirtschaft
oder für Autokratien
Dokument ist committed deshalb
arbeitet die deutsche Regierung gerne
mit ihnen allen daran dass diese neue
Konvention noch dieses Jahr angenommen
wird es gibt noch einen dritten Punkt
den wir nicht vergessen sollten
es geht um unsere Nachbarn und Freunde
wenn ich in eine andere Region gereist
bin nach Kasachstan letztes Jahr habe
ich junge Frauen getroffen in ihren
20ern die für eine NGO gearbeitet haben
und sich politisch engagieren wollten
und plötzlich hat die eine Frau gesagt
ihr seid ihr habt so viel Glück in
Europa ich habe mich gefragt was sagt
sie denn jetzt sie hat gesagt er hat so
viel Glück ihr habt den
Europarat und ich habe da kurz inne
gehalten und habe mich
gefragt meinst jetzt die EU oder den
Europarat und ich habe gefragt ja und
ich habe gefragt warum denn sie meinte
weil ihr ein Instrument habt
und dass eure Regierung reagieren muss
es gibt Konventionen
und da könnte eine NGO wie unsere sagen
ihr haltet die Menschenrechtskonvention
oder die Istanbuler Konvention nicht ein
denn es gibt diesen Gerichtshof vor dem
jedes Individuum eine Beschwerde
einreichen kann ich denke das ist ganz
wichtig in dieser Zeit es gibt so viele
Menschen vor allem auf der ganzen Welt
bei denen es gar keine Frage ist dass
Demokratie nicht geographisch ist
diese Menschen sagen wir möchten gerne
von eurer Erfahrung aus der
Vergangenheit lernen heute morgen habe
ich den Europäischen
Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte besucht
und
da habe ich gesehen was diese junge Dame
in Kasachstan meinte ich bin da
reingegangen und das ist ganz
interessant wenn wir gerade von KI noch
gesprochen haben und
danach wahnsinnig viel Post auf dem
Tisch und echte Menschen haben diese
ganzen Briefe durchgelesen und das
passiert uns auch als PolitikerInnen in
unserem Büro ist manchmal sagt das ist
aber ein bisschen verrückt aber die
Lesen wirklich jeden Brief durch Briefe
die auf Papier geschrieben worden
manche werden auch online vorgelegt aber
es gibt auch Briefe die auf einem
winzigen Blatt Papier geschrieben worden
denn wenn man im Gefängnis sitzt wenn
man einen polit ihre Häftling ist dann
hat man natürlich nicht den besten
Zugang zu diesen Gerichtshof unserem
Gerichtshof
jedes Individuum kann eine Beschwerde
einreichen und das kann auch in Form
einer handgeschriebenen Beschwerde sein
die auf einer Postkarte steht oder auf
einem Stück Klopapier das aus einem
Gefängnis gesendet wurde so einfach ist
es das ist auch die Seele Europas
an vielen Orten der Welt haben die
Menschen dieses Privileg nicht
wir dürfen das nie vergessen wir müssen
uns jeden Tag daran erinnern deswegen
liegt es an uns diese Menschen zu
unterstützen die auf der ganzen Welt für
Menschenrechte kämpfen die sich Frieden
und eine bessere Zukunft und ihre Kinder
wünschen
die Arbeit der
Kommission ist ein Beispiel dafür wie
unsere Arbeit die ganze Welt
beeinflussen kann
man könnte natürlich sagen dass diese
Kommission
keine Ware macht hat aber sie haben mehr
Einfluss als wir denken ich spreche von
der Venedig-Kommission
am Einfluss auf
Verfassungen auf Wahlrecht das ist ein
Kompass für die Demokratie die den
Mitgliedsstaaten
Anhaltspunkte gibt und zwar aus fünf
Kontinenten also von der ganzen Welt wir
könnten hier noch sehr lange weiter
sprechen sie wissen es besser als ich
sie wissen welche versteckt aber
wirklich mächtigen
Instrumente der Europarat an der Hand
hat es liegt an uns ob wir sie nutzen
oder nicht beachten es ist unsere
Verantwortung wir sind die Politiker und
Politikerin unserer Ära
wenn Menschenrechte in Gefahr sind wenn
die Menschenwürde in Gefahr ist
wenn nationalgrenzen dann werden
nationalgrenzen irrelevant
so hat es der Holocaust Überleben der
gesagt von dem wir am Anfang gesprochen
habe wir müssen vorsichtig sein und
aufmerksam wenn Menschenrechte verletzt
werden
für uns hier klingt das vielleicht
hoffnungsvoll und schön aber für die
Jungen und Mädchen und chakiff für die
16-jährige die aus Italien zurückgekehrt
ist in ihrer Heimatstadt in ein
zerstörtes Haus
weil das ihr
europäischer Boden ist ihre europäische
Seele für diese Menschen ist das ihre
Zukunft ihr Vertrauen
sind diese Worte eine Aufforderung für
uns
aufzustehen für das was dieser Rat hier
verkörpert Menschenrechte und würde für
alle Menschen vielen Dank
[Applaus]
vielen Dank
nicht der Deutsche Bundestag wo man nach
jedem zweiten Satz applaudiert aber ich
hoffe Sie verstehen dass der Applaus für
sie zeigt dass wir stolz darauf sind
dass ein EOS Mitglied dieser Versammlung
jetzt eine der führenden PolitikerInnen
Europas ist und immer noch unsere Sache
vertritt und die Sachen die uns am
Herzen liegen vielen Dank
sie haben sich bereit erklärt auch
Fragen zu beantworten
also die Fragen sind auf 30 Sekunden
begrenzt bitte nicht länger
zunächst die Fragen der Fraktionen und
dann schauen wir wie viel andere Fragen
wir noch aufnehmen können
also die Fraktion der Grünen und
sozialen aus der Türkei Celine vielen
Dank
Ministerin im Namen der Sozialamt Karl
und Grünen sie zurück wie uns ist klar
wie entscheidend der Gipfel von
Reykjavik ist und welche Bedeutung hat
könnten sie doch zu noch mehr sagen was
glauben sie werden die entscheidenden
Säulen einer neuen strategischen Vision
sein die in einem politischen
Handlungsplan münden muss ein
Aktionsplan der hoffentlich aus dem
Gipfel hervorgeht und welche Schritte
sollten unternommen werden um
zu beschleunigen dass die EU den
Konvention des Europarates be
wir sind ja haben wir auch eine Rolle im
Erweiterungsprozess der EU zu spielen
und sie haben in ihrer Rede ja davon
gesprochen Räume zu öffnen in einer
renovierten Familie von Werten nicht nur
einem geografischen Raum Frau Ministerin
die ersten Teil Ihrer Frage ich habe
versucht das in meiner Rede zu
umreißen habe ich versuche das jetzt
noch mal kürzer und prägnanter ich
glaube es geht nicht um Visionen es geht
um das jetzt das Hier und Heute um die
Zeit in der will und das Schlimmste was
passieren könnte wäre zu sagen in 20
Jahren sollten wir dies und jedes
erreicht haben denn das ist eine
großartige Entschuldigung für Politiker
warum sie es nicht hier und jetzt tun
können für mich ist dieser Gipfel eher
ein Gipfel der sich mit der Realität
befasst hat mit Visionen und obwohl das
jetzt nicht wirklich philosophisch ist
oder die Frage der Finanzierung ist so
entscheidend dabei denn man kann ja die
tollsten Visionen haben wenn man nicht
das Geld hat um diese Vision dieser
Institution zu finanzieren ich bin ja
nicht nur als
Parlamentariern hier gewesen ich war ja
auch Praktikantin hier und ich erinnere
mich daran wie meine Chefin ich wusste
ob sie dies Budget für das nächste
Quartal kriegt also wenn man an
Demokratie und Menschenrecht und
Rechtsstaatlichkeit glaubt dann haben
die
sollten die Mitarbeiter dieses Hauses
sich nicht fragen müssen ob Ihre
Bezahlung in Zukunft gesichert ist und
dass du betrifft nicht nur den
Europarats sondern auch den Europäischen
Gerichtshof denn da wird von
verschiedenen Ländern gehen da
verschiedene Beschwerden ein dass sie
das kaum täglich doch bewältigen können
und ich rufe jetzt auch die anderen
Länder auf wenn wir nicht unsere
freiwilligen Beiträge anheben dann
werden wir diese Aufgabe nicht erfüllen
können also mein erstes Ziel für den
Gipfel ist dass wir das Budget des Rates
erhöhen aber auch das Gerichtshof der
zweite Punkt ich habe versucht das auch
in der Rede zu sagen
für mich geht es darum und es für uns
wirklich auf die wichtigsten Punkte
fokussieren und das sind die
Verletzungen der Menschenrechte wenn
solche verletzende Menschenrechte
stattfindet dann müssen wir agieren und
wir haben in den letzten elf Monaten
gesehen wozu der Rat in der Lage ist
wenn er einig agiert gegen um Russland
zurückzuweisen und wenn wir hier das
durchziehen dann können wir das auch für
andere Länder und für die Verletzung von
Menschenrecht den anderen Ländern
schaffen der dritte Teil betrifft die
neuen Konventionen
eine Institution ist nur so stark wie
sie Schritt hält mit der Entwicklung der
neuen und das bedeutet neue Resolution
neue Konventionen und natürlich auch den
Kampf gegen die Klimakrise das Recht für
einen sauberes und gesundes eine sauber
und gesunde Umwelt das ist ein
Sicherheitsteam ein Top Sicherheitsthema
und deswegen ist das für mich für den
nächsten Gipfel der dritte Teil auf den
wir uns konzentrieren müssen auf die
Rechte der nächsten Folge Generation die
nächste Frage
sie spielt für Sprit für die EVP Gruppe
vielen Dank ich wollte sie ursprünglich
Fragen nach einem Sondertribunal
im Hinblick auf Russlands Aggression in
der Ukraine aber ich verstehe dass sie
damit unserem Rat übereinstimmt das ein
solches Tribunal eingerichtet werden
muss nun möchte ich Sie fragen was ihre
Position zur Lieferung von Leopard
Panzern an die Ukraine ist Freiheit und
Demokratie für die Ukraine
sind das allerwichtigste ich verstehe
dass sie nicht dagegen sind das andere
Länder leopardanzer in Ukraine liefern
aber Deutschland wurde gedrängt selber
auch Beiträge zu leisten
meine Positionen dazu ist sehr klar sie
könnten das in den letzten zwei Tagen im
Fernsehen hören aber weil ich jetzt hier
in Europa habe Europa hat Sitze möchte
ich mich jetzt nicht verstecken vor
einer Antwort sie können das natürlich
in den Nachrichten lesen aber die
Ukraine braucht mehr militärische
Unterstützung aber nicht nur von einem
Land wie in meinem Land in USA sondern
von uns allen wir können diesen Krieg
nur gemeinsam
durchfechten das es geht um unsere
gemeinsame europäische Friedensordnung
und im Hinblick auf Panzer und andere
Unterstützung erfordert dies wirklich
internationale Unterstützung der
Europarat liefert natürlich keine Panzer
und ich sage Gott sei Dank denn wir
können soll auch keine Doppelrollen hier
schaffen hier geht es darum für
Gerechtigkeit und zu sagen das schuldige
zu Verantwortung zu ziehen also es geht
um Rechenschaftspflicht hier geht es
nicht nur militärisches handeln von
Russland dieser Krieg Russlands gegen
die Ukraine gegen die europäische
Friedensordnung ist auch ein Angriff auf
unserer rechts-system was greift
Institution mit den Europarat an das
internationale Strafrecht wird
angegriffen und ich spreche hier als
Außenministerin von Deutschland aber
auch als Europäerin ja wir müssen mehr
Militärhilfe liefern aber wir müssen vor
allen Dingen auch beim Bereich der
humanitärenhilfe mehr leisten
Winterhilfe
Rechenschaftspflicht
müsste Personen aufspüren und und und
also es geht was ich hier sage wir
halten natürlich unsere militärische
Unterstützung aufrecht aber wir werden
auch darauf drängen dass die humanitäre
Hilfe weitergeht das stabilisierungs
Bemühungen voran fortgesetzt werden und
das vor allen Dingen die Schuldigen zu
Rechenschaft gezogen werden und da kann
der Gerichtshof eine entscheidende Rolle
spielen genau wieder international
Strafgerichtshof vielen Dank Frau
Ministerin
[Musik]
einer weiteren Fraktion
ich möchte
im Namen der Elder Group in gratulieren
zu ihrer Rolle der alte group also es
geht um sie setzen sich ja auch ein für
die Stärkung der Rolle von Frauen der
Rechte von Frauen ohne angegriffen zu
werden also wir haben keine Sicherheit
für Frauen die ihre Rechte waren aber
handeln ist wichtiger als Worte als alte
Fraktion wollen wir wissen wie das denn
jetzt in die Praxis umgesetzt werden
soll nicht nur für die Menschen in
Europa
wir natürlich eine große iranische
Diaspora in vielen unserer Stadt sondern
auch für die Menschen in der Ukraine wir
hatten gerade einen Bericht gehört über
sexuelle Gewalt in Konfliktsituationen
ja es ist großartig dass sie dieses
Tribunal einrichten wollen aber wie
können wir sicherstellen dass auch
Tier Personen zur Rechenschaft gezogen
werden die sexuelle Gewalt gegen Frauen
und Mädchen und Jungs und Männer ausüben
vielen Dank für diese wichtige Frage
denn Worte zählen natürlich nur wenn sie
in die Praxis umgesetzt werden ich würde
allerdings sagen dass allein schon über
diese Verbrechen zu sprechen
entscheidend ist wenn Sie sich daran
erinnern im Hinblick auf den Balkan
Krieg da hörten wir damals von vielen
Seiten das Vergewaltigung
im Krieg halt vorkommt und ich höre das
immer noch in das höre ich in Äthiopien
warum spricht man über vergewaltigt
sondern normal im Krieg aber da musst du
sein die Tat von Frauen in Bosnien in
vielen anderen Ländern das balkern sie
sagt nein das ist nicht normal und wir
müssen dagegen kämpfen und wir mussten
vor dem international Strafgerichtshof
der damals eingerichtet wurde dafür
kämpfen dass Vergewaltigung und sexuelle
Gewalt als Verbrechen gewertet werden
und das nicht einfach unterwegs
Verbrechen mit läuft das war ein
wichtiger Kampf und ich sorge dafür dass
das gehört findet denn wir haben da
nicht nur vor dem interessanten
Strafgerichtshof zu kämpfen hat habe ich
nicht nur über ein Sondertribunal
gesprochen sondern auch über die
Notwendigkeit die Rechenschaftspflicht
für solche Verbrechen weiter zu
entwickeln
wir hatten die Urteile gegen is-kämpfer
in Deutschland und die Jesi die Frauen
vergewaltigt und versklavt haben und
deswegen spreche ich immer darüber in
meinem Land in anderen Länder das ist es
so viel einfacher für Strafverfolgung in
Deutschland gegen Terrorismus
terrorismusfälle vor Gericht zu bringen
als solche Fälle selbst jetzt
hat unser Chef Ankläger unsere
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft eine eigene
Abteilung für
für Verfahren gegen Terroristen aber in
Sachen Terrorismus aber nicht in Sachen
sexuelle Gewalt so was gibt es noch
nicht daran müssen wir arbeiten
wir müssen daran arbeiten dass auch
solche Fälle vor Gericht gebracht werden
wir müssen zum Iran
tätig werden deswegen habe ich so viel
Lobbyarbeit geschrieben für den Menschen
für eine Resolution des
menschenrechtsrats damit die Situation
im Iran untersucht wird natürlich
niemand jetzt hinfahren aber das
knallige Geld für die Ukraine wir müssen
jetzt die Beweise sammeln vielleicht
auch von der aus wir müssen jetzt eine
sonderstaatsanwaltschaft einrichten
genauso damals gemacht im Fall der
jesidischen Frauen und wer hat konnten
dann die Täter zur Rechenschaft ziehen
im Namen der Täter im Namen der Opfer
pardon also es gibt sehr viel zu tun
noch auf der institutionellen Ebene aber
die Benennung der Verbrechen ist mal der
erste Schritt und die rechenschaftlich
kommt dann
als nächstes und wir müssen die
revolutionären Garten im Iran auch als
das bezeichnen was sie sind nämlich als
touristische Organisation gegen die
eigene Bevölkerung wir wissen noch nicht
ob wir die rechtliche Grundlage haben
dafür sie mit Sanktionen zu belegen aber
das ist wichtig wir hatten gestern eine
rechtsdebatte im Parlament und da sitzt
ja mein deutscher Kollege wir haben
darüber im Auswärtigen Ausschuss
diskutiert dass Sanktionsregime gegen
Terroristen wurde zu nein eleven seiner
Zeit eingeführt
aber gestern die Kollegen aus Frankreich
den Niederlangen und ich dazu aufgerufen
dieses Sanktionsregime auch oder die
Möglichkeit zu untersuchen ob diese
Sanktionsregime gegen terroristische
Aktivität auch gehen die
revolutionsgarten angewendet werden die
Menschen in Europa glauben und an die
Rechtsstaatlichkeit und Vertrauen darauf
selbst an den schwierigsten Zeiten wie
zum Beispiel bei der Einrichtung eines
sanktionsregimes muss das auf
rechtschaffen rechtsstaatlichen
Grundlagen beruhen damit das am Ende
auch vor Gericht Bestand hat und das
dauert manchmal Zeit aber das Vertrauen
in die Rechtsstaatlichkeit ist das
wichtigste vielen dank
vielen Dank Frau Ministerin
Königreich
im Namen der konservativen
Frau Ministerin sie scheinen ihr sie ja
nicht einzuräumen aber heute haben sie
wirklich die
machtvollste Rede dafür gehalten dass
Deutschland Leopard Panzer liefern
müsste Deutschland verweigert diese
Ressourcen der Ukraine und das
verlängert den Krieg und dient Putin was
können wir tun um zu helfen ihre
großzügigen Worte über die Ukraine
umzuwandeln in Handeln seitens ihrer
Regierung wenn das Parlament der
Vereinigten Königreichs in einem Punkt
einig sein kann warum kann das nicht das
deutsche Parlament Frau Ministerin
dieselbe Frage Antwort wie gestern im
Außen im Auswärtigen Ausschuss im
Treffen der Außenminister jetzt
aufeinander mit Fingern zu zeigen bringt
kein weder Frieden noch Freiheit für die
Ukraine wenn wir anfangen dieses Spiel
weiter zu spielen mit dem Finger auf
andere zu zeigen weil das will einen
selber bequemer ist dann gewinnt Putin
und deswegen naturlich das Gegenteil und
deshalb ist es so dass sie
derokratischen Politiker in meinem Land
wo wir eine Regierung mit verschiedenen
Akteuren haben wir diskutieren um dann
gemeinsam handeln zu können und deswegen
rufe ich jetzt nicht weder er rufe ich
wieder ihr noch ein anderes Land auf und
sag ja warum habt ihr nicht schon längst
Leopard Panzer geliefert oder andere
System oder warum dauert es so lange
dass Bradley Panzer geliefert werden
also das wird nirgendwohin
führt nur in Spaltung in Europa und
deshalb habe ich auch in den letzten
Tagen schon gesagt ja wir müssen mehr
tun für die Verteilung der Ukraine ja
wir müssen auch mehr im Bereich der
Panzer tun aber das wichtigste ist dass
wir das gemeinsam tun und dass wir jetzt
nicht uns gegenseitig schuldzuweisen in
Europa weil wir ein Krieg gegen Russland
führen und nicht gegeneinander
die eine Fraktion ist der Sprecher der
vereinigten europäischen Linken aus
Griechenland ich möchte gern Ihre
persönliche Meinung zu den Themen haben
was in der Sache Julien Assange sie
haben ja unsere Resolution in der
Vergangenheit unterstützt wo stehen sie
heute
zweitens
die deutsche
Waffenexporte in die dabei ein Land das
jetzt in drei anderen Ländern
besatzungsgruppen stehen hat Syrien Irak
und Zypern finden Sie das vereinbar mit
der gemeinsamen Position der EU von 2008
die militärische mit der Exporte in
Ländern
verbietet die regionale Stabilität
gefährden oder nicht zu ihren
internationalen Verpflichtungen stehen
Frau Ministerin
zur ersten Frage war meine Position
in der Opposition und aus Ministerin das
als europäisches Land natürlich jedes
europäische Land zweite Königreich
Deutschland oder Polen sich daran halten
muss was der menschenrechtshof
entschieden hat und im Fall das gilt für
den Fall Julien Assange wie für jeden
anderen Fall zum Thema Waffenlieferungen
wir haben
Gesetze dazu in Deutschland auch
europäische Regulierung auch da sind wir
dann entscheiden und wir sprechen von
einer Zeitenwende in Deutschland
hier wird von gemeinsam
Waffenlieferungen auch gesprochen wir
müssen uns klar machen
dass wir eine gemeinsame europäische
Waffenproduktion bauen wir haben jetzt
ja in den NATO und EU-Vertrag
Verpflichtungen übernommen aber in
unserer militärischen Ausrüstung sind
wir nicht so
gut aufeinander abgestimmt
das in der Ukraine die Munition nicht
funktioniert für bestimmte Waffensysteme
die aus dem anderen Land geliefert
wurden also wenn wir über Regulierungen
sprechen und militärischer
rissmilitärische Rüstungsexporte dann
glaube ich das ist keine individuelle
einzelstaatliche Entscheidung sondern
das muss eine europäische Frage sein wir
haben
eine gemeinsame Haltung der europäischen
Partner aber wenn wir vorangehen wollen
auch im Hinblick auf
Abschreibungen und Friedenssicherung in
Europa dann müssen wir nicht mehr
militärische
die Menschen
ausrüstungsgüter berücksichtigen sondern
auch exportfragen wir haben klare
Richtlinien dazu in Deutschland im
Hinblick auf Waffenlieferung in
Konfliktgebieten und Gebiete wo massive
Menschenrechtsverletzungen stattfinden
und das ist aber immer eine
Einzelfallentscheidung und deswegen
haben wir Maßnahmen ergriffen in der
Vergangenheit im Hinblick auf die
Ukraine unterstreichen wir gerade dass
wenn es um Selbstverteidigung geht dass
wir dann nach Artikel 51 der un-karte
jetzt auch in Waffen in die Ukraine
liefern obwohl dies ein Konflikt Gebiet
ist vielen Dank Frau Ministerin wir
haben jetzt keine Zeit mehr aber ich
würde noch vier weitere Fragen zulassen
die wir zusammenfassen und dann
haben sie ein paar Sekunden für die
Antwort
wir haben ja auch noch die
Feierstunde zur Erinnerung an den
Holocaust
wir haben jetzt
erstmal aus Armenien 30 Sekunden vielen
Dank Frau Ministerin in der letzten
Woche hat das Europäische Parlament eine
Resolution gegen die Blockade von
[Musik]
Aserbaidschan verabschiedet
die wie wollen Sie sicherstellen dass
die Menschen von der garni Karabach
nicht mehr als Geiseln gehalten werden
was
plant die deutsche Regierung auf diese
Situation
eine Frage wird das gelatin aus Rumänien
Frau Ministerin wie Sie wissen
dankbar für die Unterstützung der
Ukraine gegen die russische Aggression
gleichzeitig haben wir in einigen dieser
Staaten in den letzten Jahren
im Sorge angesammelt und Enttäuschung im
Hinblick auf die Behandlung
nationaler Minderheiten
es gibt eine neue Gesetzgebung über
Minderheiten und verletzt Gesetze die
Glaubensfreiheit verletzten meine Frage
ist sehr einfach die bewertet die
deutsche Regierung diese Fragen und wie
wird dabei berücksichtigt dass das
politische Kriterien für EU-Beitritt in
vielen dank vielen Dank
aus Österreich vielen Dank
in Den Haag beim Internationalen
Gerichtshof und da haben sie auch neben
dem sonder Tribunal gesagt das ist in
ein großes Anliegen ist die
verschleppten Kinder aus Ukraine wieder
zurückzubekommen ja welche Maßnahmen
setzen sie setzt Deutschland dafür dass
diese Kinder wieder zurück zu ihren
Eltern kommen
danke sehr
Ukraine hat die letzten 30 Sekunden
vielen Dank
meine Kollegen danken Ihnen und Sie
sagen thanks und ich sage thanks also
ich sage nicht nur danke ich sage auch
Panzer hier geht's um Frieden und
Gerechtigkeit dass es richtig aber
Frieden und Gerechtigkeit heute haben
einen Namen Leopard also bitte sagen Sie
uns direkt ja oder nein und wann
[Applaus]
gesagt wir haben jetzt keine Zeit mehr
aber vielleicht versuchen Sie diese vier
Fragen zu beantworten
vielen Dank für alle Ihre Fragen auch
für die Emotionen insbesondere
im Hinblick auf die Fall dass wir sind
ja direkt betroffen ihre Familie ihre
Freunde leben in der Ukraine und sie
haben jeden Tag dem Tod ins Auge zu
blicken ich verstehe das vollkommen also
ich verstehe auch Ihre Frage aber meine
Diskussion bedeutet das Frieden nicht
nur von Panzern Abhängung obwohl das
eine entscheidende Frage ist deswegen
müssen wir das intensiv diskutieren
haben das auch in unsere Regierung getan
deswegen haben wir auch Panzer geliefert
geparaden Maler
gepanzerte Fahrzeuge also im
luftersystem
aber deswegen habe ich hier überall
gesprochen
der letzten Monate und die möchte ich
mit ihm auch teilen ist ja das ist nicht
eine simple Frage gibt ob wir jetzt
Leopard Panzer liefern
hätten wäre der Krieg vorbei hieß es
aber leider nicht denn was Putin ja
macht ist so irrational das müssen wir
begreifen das ist keine Logik wenn wir
einen Schritt tun dann folgt daraus
nicht automatisch der andere Schritt von
der Gegenseite und das macht es so
kompliziert ich stimme Ihnen vollkommen
zu wir brauchen alles dafür damit die
Ukraine sich verteidigen kann
ihre Kinder ihre Großeltern und es geht
ja um die verteile europäischen Frieden
sie brauchen mehr militäre Unterstützung
ob mit dem Hinblick auf Panzer
Luftabwehrsysteme Munition aber wir
müssen auch begreifen leider das dies
vielleicht nicht verhindert dass der
Krieg weitergeht also wir müssen noch
alle anderen Faktoren berücksichtigen
und deswegen appelliere ich an sie nicht
weil ich jetzt die Militär Fragen
umgehen will nein wir brauchen jeden
jede Unterstützung humanitäre
finanzielle und besonders
die Strategie von Putin ist ja auch
Menschen nicht nur durch Raketen zu
töten sondern sie wollen die Menschen zu
Tode erfrieren lassen wir brauchen da
Unterstützung wir brauchen Minenräumen
und Projekte und das ist etwas was jedes
Land tun kann mein Land Irland und das
ist meine Appell hier lassen sie uns
diskutieren über Panzer gut und wir
werden eine Antwort liefern das kann ich
Ihnen versprechen aber lasst uns nicht
vergessen welche anderen Aufgaben vor
uns liegen die sind mindestens genauso
wichtig wie die militärische
Unterstützung auch in der Zukunft wenn
wir über den Wiederaufbau sprechen
auf die Frage der österreichischen
Kollegen danke dass Sie das angesprochen
haben die deportieren von Kindern denn
hier die Verstärkung von Kindern denn
hier haben wir
festgestellt dass das Internet seine
Komitee vom Roten Kreuz nicht mehr in
die Ostukraine gehen kann das ist auch
mal ein Argument der warum ich sage wir
brauchen mehr militärische Unterstützung
um diese Bereiche zu befreien wir wissen
nicht wie es denn den Kindern dort
wieder fahren ist wir haben dort keine
direkten Informationen deswegen sage ich
allen ihr solltet einfach mehr
diplomatische Bemühungen an den Tag
legen und nicht so Putin sprechen nein
das geht nicht wenn er bereit wäre zu
Diplomatie wäre das erste doch dass er
humanitären Zugang erstatten würde in
die Ostukraine dass er zulassen würde
dass nicht nur Soldaten sondern auch
Kinder und Familien behandelt werden und
da ist offenbar nicht bereit dazu
spricht nicht darüber wer mir keine
sicheren zahlen wir wissen also nicht ob
es tausende oder 10.000 von Kindern sind
die verschleppt wurden aber selbst wenn
es nur 100 sind dann müssen wir uns um
jedes Kind kümmern das ist mehr als
Kriegsverbrechen wenn man ein Kind
anderes Land deportiert und es ist so
Adoption freige gibt also wir schauen
gemeinsam mit dem Europarat mit dem
Strafgerichtshof mit den EU Akteuren
versuchen wir feststellen wohin sind die
Kinder verschwunden was können wir tun
um sie zurückzubringen in ihr Land und
um die zu Rechenschaft zu ziehen und vor
Gericht zu stellen die diese Verbrechen
begangen haben um die Ukraine zu
unterstützen ihren Bemühungen um zu
verhindern dass weitere Kinder
verschleppt werden denn das es gibt ja
auch da viele Fake News in der aus
Ukraine das sind kleine Schritte winzige
Schritte aber der wichtigste Schritt ist
nicht zu schweigen zu diesem Thema nur
weil wir nicht sicher sind wie groß die
Zahlen sind
die Frage zu Rumänien es tut mir leid
vielleicht habe ich die Frage nicht
richtig verstanden was sie verstanden
hat dass es um Minderheitenrechte in der
Ukraine geht das diskutieren wir mit
Ungarn und anderen Ländern im
Außenministerrat der EU offenbar ist es
ja so dass wir nicht nur ein
geographisches Europa sind sondern eine
gemeinsame Wertegemeinschaft im
Europarat und in der EU deswegen haben
wir gesagt
um die Mitgliedschaft in der EU ging das
ja die Ukraine zur EU gehört aber Sie
müssen alle europäischen
Konventionen erfüllen und da geht es
auch um Schutz von Winterreifen
Minderheit und ich bin sehr beeindruckt
dass sie selbst in Kriegszeiten die
istanbul-konvention unterzeichnet haben
dass sie an so vielen rechtlichen
Aspekten in ihrer Verfassung und ihren
staatlichen Gesetzen Arbeit und das
betrifft auch Minderheitenrechte also
das ist auch Arbeit die wir mit dem
Europarat leisten auch mit der EU und zu
Armenien vielen Dank dass Sie dieses
Thema aufgebracht haben das zeigt ja
dass wir leider nicht nur ein Krieg in
Russland in der Ukraine Russland in der
Ukraine haben sondern auch weitere
regionale Konflikte haben den wir
Aufmerksamkeit widmen müssen das ist
auch die Situation im Hinblick auf die
Blockade das und gestern haben wir als
Europäische Union entschieden eine
EU-Mission nach zu entsenden und diese
Mission ist natürlich nur dann sinnvoll
wenn es auch
von der aserbaidschanischen Seite gibt
und das Wichtigste ist dass auch diese
Mission arbeiten kann ist das ja auch
von aserbaidschanischem Boden aus
arbeiten kann um die humanitäre
Situation zu überwachen überwachen zu
können in der kommen in Konfliktgebiet
und auch dort Gerechtigkeit die Menschen
so in vielen Dank für diesen Austausch
vielen Dank auch für die Diskussion das
zeigt dass wir eine Demokratie sind und
demokratische Länder in der jeder seine
eigene freie Meinung äußern kann das
Wichtigste aber ist einander zuzuhören
um bereit zu sein das auch von Ihrer
Seite aus zu betrachten vielen Dank für
diese